- But I want this hour
to be a place of joy,
fun and connection every day.
And that doesn't mean we
have to tune out the negative
and pretend it doesn't exist,
that doesn't help change anything.
It just means that this
is a place to tune in
to like what's positive.
I feel we need things that
kind of link us and connect us.
I feel like there's a lot
of news out there already
that divides us.
So while we will address everything,
we do wanna do things in
a more positive way here.
Alright. So are y'all
ready for some positivity?
(crowd cheering)
(zoom call beeping)
What?
Oh my gosh!
What up DJ Khaled?
(crowd cheering)
- Yo Kelly that's you?
- Yes what's up are you my surprise?
- Look like you're doing
a show or something,
I'm supposed to be
getting my poker game on
with Josh Groban, you know,
get to the bag what's going on?
- Wait, what?
No, this is no, this is,
you just zoomed my show.
This is "The Kelly Clark's
Show", you know, this is my show.
- Oh no, you know I got love for you,
but I think I'm on the wrong Zoom.
- Oh, okay.
Well, you should drop by for
musically, but that's fine.
That's totally cool.
I wasn't invited to a poker
game, that's totally fine.
But while you're here,
like I'm just saying,
could you maybe give us a major key
for season two inspiration?
I mean, you're here, We're here, why not?
- Oh, cool.
Kelly, you know, I got love for you.
(crowd cheering)
The major key is to make sure
they watch "The Kelly Clarkson Show"
'cause it's gotta put
a smile on your face.
(Kelly screaming)
And that's a major key alert.
(crowd cheering)
- Yes, I love that major key.
DJ Khaled, I'll get you the
wright number for Josh Groban.
It's fine.